oh thank you so much this is the warmest
welcome I've ever got so I will remember
this and before I start my talk of
course I would love to say thank you to
the organizers to Adam who asked me to
join so the noble initiative AstraZeneca
paying and for the University and for
the Dean organizing this and to all of
you that you want to spend one hour with
me and try to understand what we are
doing far north so I hope you get some
IDs so I'm interested and I hope that
when I'm done here then you have some
ideas how memory is encoded in the brain
what is necessary to make memories and I
give you some cure cell space-time is
important once upon a time there was a
tiny girl and she had one mission in her
life and that was to try to understand
the word and it developed into this idea
I want to understand how the brain is
generating behavior memory our cognition
our emotions and you know what happened
then this girl she was so lucky that she
became a scientists and as a scientist
she was allowed to ask these questions
in the lab and what also happened was
that
I experienced something that I want to
share with you because it's a way to
show you one of my memories
it happened in 2014 and I was sitting in
Trondheim I was talking to the people in
the lab we had exciting discussion and
then I got a very annoying phone call I
understood after a while that the
message was not
[Music]
okay so this was a memory I wanted to
share with you and what is important
here is that this is an example of a
very strong episodic memory and under
tuning in the 70s he said if you want to
study episodic memory there are three
key questions that you have to
understand and if you want to understand
how the brain is dealing with this then
you know a bit more about that the
Tzadik memory and that is what I hope
that we can do today so there are three
questions
where did it happen
when did it happen and what happened
what we also know is that there is a
brain structure just inside here in the
temporal lobe that is called hippocampus
in fact there two of them and it's
called hippocampus as you know because
it's hippocampus is seahorse and it
looks like a seahorse so this this
hippocampus here is dissected out by
person a professor in Hungary Laszlo
Sarah's just to show how similar
hippocampus is to seahorse what is
important is that even in the 50s we
heard about this structure because there
was one man that you probably have heard
about he was called a gem at that time
and I'm iliza he had removed both of his
super company because he had a plastic
seizures and the medicine didn't help
him and then they did some experimental
surgeries and to remove the per compass
he woke up and he was a very nice guy so
he was
social he was laughing he was he looked
very normal and then they started to
test him with IQ tests and he was better
than before because he wasn't disturbed
by the seizures but when people came
back even after 15 minutes he said I
never seen you before
so he couldn't encode new episodic
memory
he couldn't even know how to find a
bathroom so he didn't have the where and
he didn't have the time because he
didn't know when things had happened and
in what sequence but he could learn
other things he could learn to write
from a mirror and he could learn quite
some some things but everything that had
to do with episodic memory even to learn
that his uncle had died he couldn't
encode into his brain so in our lab we
were restarted with where but before we
started with the where question there is
an important man
besides my ex-husband Edward Moussa and
that was my supervisor John Okeefe who
we learned a Nobel Prize with what he
did was to ask there's something special
with this hippocampus structure since
it's so important for HM and other
patients if you don't have it you can't
encode episodic memory so he had done a
lot and he had small sensors close to
the cells in the hippocampus and rot was
just walking around happy so in his lab
they got rise in my lab like a chocolate
of course so what happened is that he
was just studying this rat running
around chasing rice or chocolate and
then he asked himself
if I listen to one hippocampus cell what
is this hippocampal cell reacting to can
I understand that and I'm going to play
the video and then you can see yourself
even though I have given you a cue here
so now you hear one single cell that is
active and you see the raft is doing
exactly the same thing chasing chocolate
so what is so special about this corner
we even use this the color code to show
you that there is something very hot in
that corner this cell is responding to
something in that corner and then could
it be that as a special order coulda be
some scratch in the floor what is it so
John and others recorded money cells and
I found out that each cell had its own
preference
where to be active and where to be
silent and if you record more than
hundred cells at the same time for some
time then you can predict where the
animal is with a 5 percent 5 centimeters
precision that's quite remarkable so
just by listening to the cells of this
animal you know where the animal is with
the precision of 5 centimeters that's
scary so for every to me it started
really started when we could have our
PhD defense in 1995 so hey you see at
Reston here you see me our oldest
daughter and our supervisor Perry
understand and here we have John Okeefe
so the link to go to his lab to learn
this technique to learn to record from
these single cells in the hippocampus
that was quite easy at a time we brought
two children with us and we brought this
technique to Trondheim so the first
question we had when we explored this
was exactly what I asked you about why
are these cells active and where is this
information coming from is it so that
the information is processed within the
hippocampus itself or is it fed in
structure brain structure outside the
hippocampus and in order to address that
question we had this fantastic student
who took his the medical PhD and medical
degree at the same time in our lab and
this is this is a rodent brain in fact
this is a rabbit brain drawn by my
supervisor paramedicine you see if you
lift the cortex then you see this
beautiful structure it looks like a
sausage but but but it's beautiful
and if you don't slice it you see these
lines of cells here and information in
hippocampus is coming from entorhinal
cortex it's going through this loop here
in dentate up to c3 and then up to see
you want and then back again to enter on
the cortex so we asked is it so that if
we block this loop in the hippocampus do
you still get place else
yes so we got through higher examples of
seven beautiful places even though we
cut this loop in the hippocampus so what
did I tell us the information that these
cells use to generate the place signal
has to come from outside and our best
guess that was an tryna cortex so then
we took our sensors our electrodes and
we decided to place these electrodes in
the internal cortex so this is a brain
rat brain that you see from behind the
cerebellum is removed and this colorful
area here is the entorhinal cortex the
right one that is the middle and Rhyno
cortex and at a time we collaborated
with many victories now in trondheim
running his own group and we decided to
put our sense
in the most dorsal part of the middle
and around cortex people had been
recorded up before but they had recorded
down here and concluded that there is
nothing interesting so now you have to
see yourself I'm going to play another
video there's no sound but there are
some white dots telling do you see
anything good there's some strong light
tears I don't know if you see you see it
okay so you see these white dots and
this is the activity of one single cell
in this area in the internal cortex and
you see that that it looks not so nice
so maybe these people were right there's
nothing interesting in the dorsal or in
in the entry on the cortex but if you
have a big enough environment and you
have really happy animals that love to
chase chocolates so that you get enough
coverage you get the pattern that looks
like this so this is another 150 by 150
bucks
these black traces that is where the
trace of the animal and blue dots one
blue dot that is one electrical
potential from these cells and what you
see here is that there is a very regular
pattern and this is biology so it
shouldn't be so that you can fit in
equilateral triangles into a pattern
that is generated from biology and
remember how deep the cell is in the
brain so we did this together with
Mariana feenin and until Knopf think
when Mariana was a PhD student in our
lab and we decided that this cell which
is sending information to the
hippocampus might function as
the ruler a metric system in the brain
what this fascinating is that when you
go from dorsal to ventral then it's like
if you if you draw these grid cell
pattern on a balloon and you blow up
then there's an expansion when you go
more and more mental in this structure
that you see here so cell one very
torsion small fields close by and then
bigger fields further away and then you
have fields that are really big and
quite far away so why do I tell you this
because I want to bring you back to your
poor compass and ask how can you come
from these grid cells to a place that is
that possible
because that is our hypothesis yes you
can
so if you align these grid cells on top
of each other you just do a normal
linear summation then you see here in
the middle there's a bump but at the
edges everything is canceled out and
what do you get then you get one pump as
we saw in the hippocampus I have another
question to ask - and that is how carry
this cell be so precise it doesn't have
eyes it doesn't have ears it doesn't
have a nose except on the animal of
course so what type of information does
this cell need in order to be so precise
it needs to know the direction of the
animal and it needs to know the speed
because when the animal is eating
chocolate it's stopping its running fast
and it's changing position all the time
so then we asked are there such cells
close to the grid cells and Franciscus
are greenly from Rome she came to a lab
and she showed that are some cells
to the grid cells that we call head
Direction cells and they were not
discovered by us because they were
discovered in another brain area by a
gym rank and Toby but she found them in
an Tron aquatic speed medial and Toronto
cortex so these cells work like this so
when the animal is going west
then his Papa Papa Papa and then there's
another cell so it doesn't help if
they're a novela is going only to west
but it has to point north in order to
get this cell to be active so this
information is then giving to given to
the grid cell but we also need
information about the speed of the
animal and then the question this
argentinian a postdoc had from Patagonia
Emilia crops he asked is there a
speedometer in the brain feeding the
grid cells with information and he
designed a car for the rats because if
you want to find cells that respond to
the speed of the animal you have to
control the speed of the animal and then
if you can decide the speed of the car
then it's fine
but it's not completely fine because the
animal might fall asleep so how can you
keep the animal awake animal has to run
and that is why we have the Flintstone
car here to remind us that the animal is
running and in this way
Emilio could change the speed of the
animal as much as he wanted and I can
show you one example of such an
experiment that he did so here the
animal is running north and here the
animal is running south these lines
adjusted in individual laps that animal
is running and these red dots that is
just where the animal or the cell is
active and you see when the speed is
high the same is
very very active and when the speed is
slow the activists or address the cell
is almost silent and it doesn't matter
whether animal is traveling north or
south
the cell is signaling exactly the speed
of the animal and that is what we see
also in 2d so when the animal is just
running chasing chocolates in a box like
you have seen how so many times on these
videos so here we have 12 cells and what
you see here is that the pattern and the
firing pattern is not interesting but
what is interesting is to see the
correlation between the activity of the
cell at the y-axis and the speed of the
animal and you see it's a beautiful
linear summation so these two types of
cells they inform the grid cells about
the speed of the animal and direction
then we asked the question how is this
process running and we had two Chinese
postdocs now
Chetan and we are asked together with
them is it so that the gaba
the inter neurons are they involved in
the precision of the firing of the grid
cells so to address that question they
ordered cream eyes that had a creativity
on the part of mean cells and also the
somatostatin and they used this
artificial receptor technique the dred
technique so you just use the virus then
that will go only to those cells that
has the critic in this mutant mice and
then you use an artificial lightened
like this you know and then you can
activate or inhibit only those cells
that
you are interested in and that is
exactly what meow and chitin did and
this is an example of three cells not
one one cell sorry so this is before
they gave to the artificial drug this is
when the drug is working and this is
when the drug is leaving the body and
you see that when there is drug in the
brain of this mouse this grid cell
doesn't look like a grid cell anymore
and if you ask the grid square how much
grid-like is there cells then you see
that when this drug is working then we
have much fewer grid cells in these mice
than before and the same thing happened
with the speed so you see here's the
speed signal when they have the drug
it's flat when the drug is out of the
body then there's a speed signal and
that is summed up here and you see that
the speed score is very very bad when
when this drug is working and then so
what we showed here is that the power of
immune cells are giving inhibition to
the grid cells to keep the correct
position of the fields and the
somatostatin
they did not have this effect but I
worked on on on different type of cells
so I'm sorry that I'm I'm rushing
because I have so much to tell you I
don't know that I have limited time so
you have to shout at me if you think
that I should move on or go a bit slower
or we have some questions at the end we
also want to compare the different maps
in the hippocampus and and the
entorhinal cortex and what is that very
very different
these maps so the grid maps they work
together all the greats
from the same motor and it's like a
mathematical paper that you bring with
you
you might rotate it you might shift it
but it's always the same and that is
illustrated here that you go from room
to room and it's absolutely the same map
this girl shall locked Alma nove general
PhD student in the lab she worked with
the hippocampus and she tested the
animals in eleven rooms and she asked is
it so that the hippocampal map is
similar to the internal map that it is
the same map that is used over and over
again or does the hippocampus create new
maps and what is a map in this case it's
the activity of the different cells so
what she did was to put all the
recordings from the different eleven
exposures to different rooms put them on
top of each other and then she asked odd
is correlated and you see here's
familiar one familiar one and of course
the same room is very correlated but
it's a lot of blue here meaning that
it's not correlated at all that means
that cells that are active in this room
are not active at all in the other rooms
except if you go back to the same room
then even after one exposure the
hippocampus is using the same map so to
just sum it up it seems like we have so
many uncorrelated maps in the
hippocampus where you can store your
memory and that is different and from
the grid cells that can rather give the
metric to the spatial input so then we
have to rush on to ask the next question
or any indication of information in the
and Tirana cortex telling the
hippocampus about time then we got this
absolutely fascinating and fantastic
PhD student he came to Norway from
Washington when he was 18 so he was
almost the same age as my daughter and I
said no way this is not good
he was so excellent you can't imagine so
he said he wanted to study the lateral
internal cortex and he was allowed to do
that so that is the sister structure of
Medellin Toronto cottage so the grid
says ah here the lateral internal cortex
that is where he put his electrodes this
poor guy he came to Edmonton me and he
showed his results and even though we
love this PhD student so much because he
was so skilled we said this is not right
because he had so unstable recordings
that we said something must be wrong and
it took him eight years and us to
discuss this and before he found out
what was wrong with the data what was
wrong with it data was that time had
been running in between and this is
illustrated in the experiment that he
and and Jurgen another PhD student or a
postdoc in the lab did so that was in
the same room you can have this
situation where the animal is running
around in this box you can have white
walls black walls and you run the animal
put the animal in the box put it back
again you clean between each and that is
exactly what happened so this is the
black box white box whatever
white box and then in between you have
this pot situation what happened with
the cells is that each individual cells
seemed to respond differently to this
situation
so if we go to this cell this cell said
I'm measuring how much time the
animal is running in the box so you see
if it's the black box the firing rate is
slow and then increasing low increasing
low increasing so it's measuring time in
or the trial time this cell is doing
something different it's measuring the
whole session starting with high firing
rate and at the end of the last white
box it is almost no firing at all and
another cell is telling about what color
the box had and also how much time the
rat was spending in each box and then
you have the same thing here with with
the world color and the different
sessions so this was the confusing part
so then Albert came up with what if we
use the general linear model to to ask
what can tell us best how can explain
the variance in these data in the best
way so then he asked what about the
world color does that explain any
variance at all and he compared the data
from the lateral entorhinal cortex which
structures that we were happy about to
see a tree from the hippocampus and
medial internal cortex and not much
happened when it was only wool color
then he asked about the position and you
see that the middle internal cortex with
the grid cells they signal position best
of these three structures then he asked
about wall color and position asking is
it a white box or black box and where is
the animal in the box then we see a tree
said hey this is my function then he
came to lateral and Rhino cortex and
lateral anterior cortex was telling
about time so it was like a clock
ticking tick tock tick tock tick tock
and giving a tag
to each episode that the animal
experienced each box and this is just
when it was mixed it didn't say much so
it seems like you have this roaming
clock that can give you a tag to every
episode ik memory so that you can sort
your episodic memories in the correct
sequence but as the spatial information
is subjective also time is subjective
and you know that maybe some of you
think that this is such a slowly moving
hour and some of you think oh time is
going so fast
and this happens also in the brain of
these animals because when the animals
were allowed to run in another task that
was very repetitive so they were asked
run and his ate maze out them down
and up and down and up and down and they
got a reward ten time between each trial
that they went to this apparatus was
gone they couldn't these cells didn't
tell much about that time but now these
cells this exactly the same selves told
about how much we're in this apparatus
is the animal because the experience is
telling you about time and this
experience is so different from running
in these different boxes how much time
do I have now
I have 10 minutes maybe or less 5 15
minutes you are an angel
Wow then I can relax
ah okay so then the last question
because when we have memories we don't
only know where it happened when it
happened
did it happen before lunch or didn't
happen after lunch but we also have
people in our memories we have objects
and for the rats it's easier for us if
we ask this what question with objects
so we have this situation for the route
or for the mouse that animal is exposed
to at deplore or Lego tower or some toys
that we put in because you remember the
other boxes they had only chocolate now
we have chocolate and a queue and Jim
Kinnear him in in the states he asked
this question first so he had these
different objects he put them in the box
did exactly what we have been doing
giving the animal chocolate and these
white circles that is that is four of
these objects and then these are
different cells that respond to these
objects and when the cell is responding
to the object you know now the code that
when there is color there is activity so
then this cell is just a object papapapa
a object is an object then how many of
you remember this guy the time guy he is
also the object guy so what he did was a
game to play so you know it's so
important when you have questions that
you really wonder how to address that
you can play so we have people in our
lab playing trying out things and
suddenly they see something that is so
exciting
so what Albert did was he was recording
them in lateral internal cortex and he
had this situation it was this box he
had to deplete our here and he had
trained a rat for 14 days and then he
said I have found some of these cells
that in cream found that respond to the
object but I want to see what happens if
I remove the object so it is like you
sit in a pot and you wait for your best
friend and your best friend's chair is
empty where is my best friend so that
happened to the RuPt the rat was walking
here in the object it had been exposed
to this object for 14 days and this cell
said something is wrong
look it's firing even though there is no
object so we decided to call these cells
tracers because they are the memories of
what was there before and then Albert
started to play so he moved the object
to a new position and you see that when
he was moving the trace was also exposed
so in this situation he had moved so
many objects and this cell responded to
all of these moved objects there's
nothing there and even cleaned the box
with alcohol with soap there's nothing
and still he says a saying I have a
memory for this place there was an
object I have a memory for this place
there was an object how much time now 10
minutes thank you
then I will end with something that is
it's already published for some years
ago because I find it so intuitive when
when you think about your episodic
memory and if you think about an odor
it's so easy to retrieve a memory can
you think about her order that can give
you a memory that you haven't been
thinking about is there some Piatt or
something that is smelling something
I'll hand back to Spain so this was
treated by Marcel Proust of course in
his novel talking about when he was a
child he was sitting with his aunt and
he got the tea and he could dip the
Madeleine cake into the tea and it was
this lovely taste then when he was a
grown-up he did the same and he was sent
back to his aunt we studied this in the
lab how can you study this in the lab
can you think about a task you need an
aunt
you need a Madeleine cake you need a cup
of tea at least we have odors in the lab
and we have the rat Emma and Amash is
giving the task that when she is
smelling chocolates she should go to
this corner and then she is getting a
reward when she is smelling banana here
then she should go to this corner and
then she gets another reward do you
think that I'm not gonna do this task
it's quite complicated yeah
should we see that was chocolate
chocolate Amana
she's good chocolate no it doesn't help
to cheat and now she is she can't
concentrate
you know rats are like offs they give up
sometimes banana yeah and now she's back
on track and what this guided Kay
Igarashi from Japan was to record
simultaneously from the hippocampus and
the lateral internal cortex when Emma
and her friends solved this task what
was so exceptional with what he did was
that he was able to record from the self
when Emma started to learn this when she
was completely naive until she had
learnt the task so he could follow the
process in the brain when these two
positions were coded and the positions
were associated with the orders and this
is this is the last complicated slide I
will promise you and it's very
complicated but we will just go through
it and then you get some idea so this is
recordings from the hippocampus and
these are recordings from the lateral
internal cortex each line here is one
cell here and another cell in lateral
internal cortex here this first panels
that is when emma is naive she doesn't
know the task at all where she has had
some trials and then this is when she is
more skilled and this is when she's very
very good doing just a few errors
and this is when she is doing errors
then you can see these colors that we
have here these colors are just the
activity the poo poo poo poop of the
different cells some cells prefer the
chocolate red and some cells prefer the
purnama
and this is where Emma is smelling the
different odors what I want you to see
here is that here the maps are quite
empty there's not so much colours but
when the animal when emma is killed you
see there's a lot of red activity and a
lot of green activity in both structures
so that means that in Emma's brain she
has developed a map that is the
combination of the odor and the place
and what happens when Emma is doing an
error her brain is empty have you ever
had this feeling that your brain is
empty that happens there's almost no
color no active cells telling Emma where
to go that's life so we think that we
have now discovered cells in the brain
that code for where something happens
when it happened and what happened and
then the hippocampus is fed this
information is receiving this
information so that the hippocampus can
generate our episodic memory there are
some people who can't do this and out is
those people who have a lesion a damage
when these cells are dead this happens
in some groups of Alzheimer's disease
patients in happens in also other people
so they have problems to encode new
memories because these says
are dead they have problems with spatial
navigation they even have problems to
encode the sequence of events this is
the group how it looked like one year
ago only address in my group and I've
told you about the people that have been
involved and of course advert has been
involved in everything we have got a lot
of support from a local University the
qebla Foundation the Research Council in
Norway the European framework in the
year see grants and we Shanti occur
madam Bittencourt supported us and so on
and then I would just like to end with
another memory that I would like to
share with you
I'm from the coasts of Norway and just
enjoy
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Thank You professor Morcerf
for your brilliant talk and as you can
see highly inspiring lecture and now the
session is open for questions so we
encourage especially young people
students young researchers to ask
questions to Professor Moses to use this
unique opportunity so is there any
question there can we get some light in
the room so we have okay yeah
first of all do some tag it's oh wow
it's obviously amazing to have you here
and I'm super excited this might be a
bit of a controversial question but um I
assume most of the rats are made for
like interference with hormones and so
but you were talking about Emma and
since spatial awareness is kind of like
a gender issue there's people saying oh
you know women have less of a spatial
awareness and memory so I was wondering
if in in the lab you've put an Emma and
their counterpart Peter let's say man if
there's any difference or all brains
after all are the same in the way that
they work with these grid cells and
space cells and head cells thank you for
asking this great question so we had
especially a postdoc from Britain Ross
Langston and when she started in lab she
said I'm only going to work with females
because I'm going to prove that females
have great selves borders as head
Direction cells and of course they do
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so we said Mannino celebre de from
castle institute in madrid thank you for
your talk it was really clear and I'm
very glad that you can come to deliver
this new data in in this fantastic venue
so my question is regarding cahal so
cahal identified the neuronal doctrine
in which the self identity is the
building block of the brain so my
question is whether do you think that
the functional categories are related
with a cell type specificity what to say
if the functional grid cells or speech
cells
oh yeah how you get functions out of the
network whether they could be related
with cell type-specific
of the internet thank you for asking
that question so so that was our dream
when we found order to discover the grid
cell because if there would be a marker
a genetic marker or something with these
grid cells saying that I'm a grid cell
if you did only Anatomy that would have
been fantastic but we haven't been able
to do that so the only the closest we
have come is this data that I showed you
from the Chinese couple in the lab where
they show that it seems like the spell
itself in layer 2 of the middle internal
cortex a receiving inhibition from the
par value in cell self around and then
in order for these cells to be active
they have to get information from the
hippocampus we have shown that by giving
you small so that we inhibited the
activity in the hippocampus and internal
cell itself
they were left alone on
we'd had inhibition that surrounded them
and another input and that is the head
direction and what happened then was
that before the grid cells disappeared
some of them became head Direction cells
so that is telling us something about
this network and that is also why we
thought this was so interesting to see
that the inter neurons staying with
somatostatin they are not involved in
generating the grid cells so we are
closer to this but what we also know is
that the cell itself are also bored
ourselves and they could have other
different functions right it doesn't
even it's not enough to just say still
it sells the grid cells so it's still a
very puzzling question but highly
exciting so we have some interesting
ideas how to solve that and we have some
wonderful wonderful postdocs working in
the lab trying to solve this question
but not the science you never know what
you get
so hey I know junk I'm not a physician
but a physicist so I want to ask what
you think would happen in outer space I
mean the pattern the grid pattern in a
different eternal force religion field
would be completely different the mind
the boon of the month or they or the
Martian will be different we adapted to
the new situation that's a wonderful
question so what happens when we go to
space
dude agreed sets Misha give us the same
metric so where some rats going out in
space but at that time they didn't know
about the grid cells they knew about
their hippocampus and places but the
experiments were so difficult so it was
just a short paragraph in science
telling rats have been in space we don't
know but the related question to you is
what happens if the animal is flying
even though it's not in outer space but
even to fly it's a different information
to you and if you count your steps and
there's a fantastic group in Israel and
animal enough ski and he is studying
bats and when the bats are flying he can
record from the hippocampus or from the
adrenal cortex and he has shown that the
hippocampal play cell is now a sphere
and then the question is and says he
come from physics how could you predict
the grid cell which should be a crystal
should it be a perfect crystal could it
be a squeezed crystal how would these
different fields be and he's still
struggling with that because to get the
coverage enough when the bat is flying
that has been difficult but the rumour
tells us that there is one 3d grid cell
that looks like a crystal but we are
still waiting science need a lot of
people
thank you so much for your speech it has
been really interesting so my question
was we don't see many female Nobel
Prizes so I would like to ask you in
your personal experience have you ever
faced any kind of discrimination against
you for being a woman that's a very
interesting question so you know this
little child that you saw a little girl
she had a bigger brother ten years older
and I wanted to be him because he was so
tough so I never realized that I was
different from the boys I didn't think
about it but of course now I'm a
grown-up I'm soon an old woman and I
have realized that the expectations that
you have towards a man and a woman it's
not always equal and of course if you
want to grow curiosity and passion if
you if you don't expect people to do
well then it's more difficult but for
some people it's whew I'm going to show
them so what I'm saying is that in
Norway we have been blessed with not so
much discrimination and not to myself
but I am aware that we have some
challenges and what is important is that
we all love science and we need
diversity we need different cultures we
need men and women young and old and we
need to talk to each other to solve
these big questions and I think we will
do that if we work together
hello thank you very much for your very
nice talk I'd like to ask okay we now
know where the information that the
hippocampus is analyzing comes from but
where is information entering our
quarters coming from
that's a brilliant one so of course we
have students in our lab one protge
student and one a postdoc and a postdoc
from from Holland working on for example
a question where's the speed information
coming from and it's not published yet
but they have been tracing the brain
stem and diagonal band and it seems like
this loop is very important for the
speed information then you have
information about the visual spatial
environments of parietal cortex is
extremely important
you have the poster on an important and
then of course the hippocampus is
sending information back to the
entorhinal cortex telling them to run
the cortex some important things and and
so under there's older information to
the lateral entorhinal cortex and what
is so special is that as I said this is
so far away from the direct sensory
organs so what we see in these
structures is what the brain is
generating from all this information
that it's receiving so that makes this
even more interesting because we go so
deep in the brain and we are trying to
understand how the brain is working how
its coding generating functions hi first
of all thank you for for your talk it
was really inspiring some surveys has
shown that younger people nowadays are
less interested in in the STEM fields so
my question is what would you tell oh I
will
how would you convince younger young
people to to get into STEM fields and
and to make science so I think that the
advice I have to both you the young ones
but also my generation is to give
opportunities for curious people to
follow their passion so if you have
passion for some questions that are
extremely important for you you can't
stop it you just have to ask this
question and that is the question I got
when we got the Nobel Prize why why
don't you do you say to sleep on your
low burner now that don't can can you
just relax don't do anything because now
you don't tick off nobel prize of course
not
because that was not the goal the goal
was to understand and if you have this
curiosity like you had when you were a
child if you just let this curiosity
grow in yourself then you find out what
is your question what do you have
passion for and if it's not science
fine enough but if it's science
welcome
[Applause]
first of all thank you for your talk it
was really amazing so about the other
cells we humans have a underdeveloped
vomeronasal nerve
unlike inferior mammals that of course
like the rat has a fully developed
boomer muscle cells I'm guessing it it
has connection with the oil how do you
call do I turn on on turn I own Toro
under renal cortex sorry so huh I'm
guessing that's the question we shall
have a slightly undeveloped other cells
I mean like the rat the rat called track
deck the order of this food it was a
chocolate or a banana it contract the
order and actually track it in a in a
space gosh
the rat was looking right he has humans
can't
so I'm that's a question so are you
asking about the vomeronasal organ or
asking about the experiment with Emma
yeah okay with Emma so so you you have
to remember that she got the chocolate
and the banana order in the same place
so it was this central place and and
both orders were there so in order for
her to know where she should go to write
or to left she had to make this
association between the order and the
position but but what is interesting in
your question is if you did this test
with me maybe having not developed my
olfactory system as well as Emma could I
do the task I don't think so because but
maybe so but what is important is that
this is a redundant system so
is back to your question because into
the hippocampus you get all kinds of
information so if you to generate for
example the grid cell under speed you
have the optical flow you have the
number of steps you have also how fast
you move so if you remove the optical
flow you can still count the number of
steps and you know how fast you have
gone so it is a very redundant system so
so you don't if you don't have the
ability to smell something you can still
do very fine so that is my only response
normally you don't when you're in a room
normally you don't know where the north
real north is so for the grid map you
need to fix the north how do you fix it
or thank you for that question
it's a wonderful question so III talked
briefly about it when it came to time
the time is so subjective and it's the
same with the metric and the grid sets
so when I told you about these compasses
I I shouldn't call them compass because
it's not connected to the magnetic north
so it is a map that is generated in US
and in the animal so when when you come
to a room for the first time these cells
just decide this is north this is east
and so on and if you don't go to a
different room having the same magnetic
or different magnetic directions then
north only can be there for this head
Direction cells the same cell so it's
just it's a system to help us to
organize life and those of you who know
a tiny bit of philosophy can't he said
you can't explore the word if you don't
have this faculty
before you start to explore so it's just
a help for us to understand the world
the mission of the tiny girl hi and
thank you very much for your talk it was
incredible
and I would like to know if you talked
about the others and the relationship
with a memory and I want to know if the
sounds have the same effect the music or
something like that could have the same
effect could be related to the memory so
absolutely and even in in patients with
memory problems some of their problems
is to find a good retrieval cue and then
you see with with really severe
Alzheimer's disease that if you play
some music that I know it sees seems
like it can circumvent and tirana cortex
and hippocampus that is damaged and then
go to a storage out in the cortex so the
challenge for a memory is interference
that you start to mix memories and also
to find a retrieval cue and that is why
odors are so fantastic because so I was
at one conference and then John Gurdon
told me about a museum in New York and
that's a Viking Museum and you know
Norwegians we are Vikings so he said at
this museum they had the Viking
exhibition and they smelt terribly these
Vikings and you could buy these terrible
smells in the souvenir shop at Museum so
John he went there and he bought these
odors and he met people that hadn't been
to this museum for 20 years and he
exposed these people from different
odors and then he asked what what do you
think about when you smell ism
oh this is the York
you know odors are even pleasant odors
are very very good retrieval cues so you
just have to find out and that is also
useful when you have to to memorize
things that you just have to memorize
that you don't understand and then you
can use this old-fashioned technique
with the memory palace which is very
useful then you use space as a retrieval
cue so you go from room to room and then
pick up your memories when you mentally
travel from room to room we have time
for only two questions there was one
question over there so I think that I
understood that many of the graphics
that you showed us we're representing
the activity of just one neuron and I
was just really curious if you could
tell us how the sentence sensors work
and are showing just the response of one
neuron oh yeah thank you for that
question so what we do is that we have
ultra thin electrodes so it's a quarter
over here that is one then we twist four
of them together and we cut them with a
golden sister so that these four are so
close like this then we put the animal
down with morphine and I suffer rain and
we open a tiny bit in the skull and then
we can insert this here thin electrodes
into the brain close to where we want to
go but then when the animal is awake and
happy running around we can turn these
electrodes down without an animal can
feel anything and then we can listen and
we can test the animal and then finally
we hear a response papapapa because we
have a camera above the animal when
animal is running so we can
tract behavior and we can track the
signals and what we do is just to
correlate two and two electrodes and ask
how does the cell look like on this so
this is extracellular recordings and in
this way we have these clouds of
activity that are separated because
there is a distance between the
electrode and the different cells and
this way you can follow these clouds for
days and weeks and even I followed some
of my cells for half-year and that's
possible because you know the signature
for each cell and you magnify these
small electrical potentials 10,000 times
so that you can see it on a similar
scope and you can listen so we've time
for one last question at the back there
I thank you for your talk I was
wondering about the encoding process
when you study those animals and you
study these grid cells and play cells
about the molecular process of how do
they encode if you have performed some
experiments for example I think about
the cinah Jocelyn's papers about the
internal cortex and how do they increase
CREB levels on those cells and they see
that they are more prone to encode this
this new information if you have to
think about this process could be
happening at your model because they
study context or fear memories but this
is another kind of memory but is very
related and also how the neurogenesis
could also interfere in the throat the
time the forgetting those memories that
you're studying hmm thank you for that
question so I can't answer you so much
because we have a postdoc in the lab
who is applying for a European Research
Council grant he's the most fantastic
postdoc from Italy and as I can't tell
his proposal but he is going to study
exactly this how how do you set up these
networks during development how can how
can you select the cells that will
become place that's their active in
these different rooms how how is the
brain dealing with this so I can say
that there will be answers to those
questions that you have but I can tell
you how is doing it I'm sorry
[Applause]
you